reading and knowledge as a way of
pushing you out of your
comfort zone famous for their other jobs
but now
two best-selling authors barack obama a
former american president
and marcus rashford footballer for
england and manchester united
i didn't start off with the thought that
i was going to end up being the
president of the united states or
make policy for my country if i had had
more talent
i would have probably preferred to be a
professional athlete
like marcus last year rashford led a
campaign to get children living in
poverty
free school meals i wasn't i wasn't
doing that at 23.
next month he launches a book club it's
designed for
getting books in the hands of kids that
otherwise wouldn't be able to
um and almost in a sense just allowing
them to dream
at a school in the town where he grew up
excitement for rashford and his book
club is brewing
she's been helping people and
in lockdown i'm looking forward to read
like he
should never give up i would normally
read quite early in the morning
and quietly at night to the point where
i'm sleeping with a book in my hands
marcus rashford and magic breakfast have
supported within shore schools all the
way through lockdown
and this is another excellent example
where they're using their initiative
to bring books into school something
that we've lost through lockdown being
able to go to libraries
puja puri's debut book is first on the
reading list with
50 000 copies set to be donated as part
of the scheme
what they are is essentially their i
think tools of empowerment so they help
give you confidence
and self-belief and i think i think i
really hope that that was something
actually that really did make me
want to be part of this book club and
part of marcus's ambition
first helping feed children and now
getting them to read
i look forward to meeting you in person
sometime soon yeah 100
no wonder marcus rashford caught the
president's attention
sadia chowdhury sky news